MIKE PROCOPIO: Well,
welcome to Google I/O 2016.
It is so great to have you
all with us here today.
My name is Mike Procopio.
I'm a software engineering
manager on the Google Drive API
team.
RANDALL SARAFA: And my
name is Randall Sarafa.
I'm a product
manager at WhatsApp.
So what we're here to
talk to you about today
is a feature we built
into WhatsApp for Android
which lets you back up
and restore your messages
from Google Drive.
And we're here to tell you
a little about how that went
and how they came together
and some of the challenges
we had with that.
MIKE PROCOPIO: OK.
So kind of a high level overview
of where we're going here
today, we'll take a look
at messaging in general,
as well as the space where
mobile devices are starting
to proliferate significantly,
and usage has really
hit an inflection point,
combined with Cloud Storage
and Google Drive in general.
We'll take a close
look at how this works,
including some technical
details from both a product
and engineering standpoint.
Along the way, we did
face several challenges.
We'll look at some
of those, what
they were, both from the product
and engineering standpoints
as well.
Taking a close look
at the Drive API,
and then followed
by a live demo.
So borrowing from Sundar's
keynote yesterday,
we truly are in the
moment of mobile.
Mobile is seeing
massive adoption.
Across the world, there are
three billion connected users.
And we are seeing over
50% of search queries
coming from mobile.
Some notes from Sundar's--
the CEO of Google--
Sundar's Founders Letter
from 2016, the mobile phone,
more and more, is the
remote control of our lives.
And we're using
these devices in ways
that we didn't even
think were possible
as few as a few years ago.
Just advance for me.
So also from Sundar,
think about it's not just
messaging and communications.
It's content generation.
It's media generation.
More and more, we're using
these phones to take pictures.
There was a tipping
point when cameras
started to show up on phones
where the barrier to entry
to actually taking a
photo, or 10 photos,
is much less than it used to be.
So take a series of 10 photos.
Sundar had noted
that, and it's not
hard to see how we
arrived at this number,
we could end up with a
trillion photos taken
across the world this year.
That seems, when you
start thinking about it,
that's may be a billion people
taking 1,000 photos a year,
if I'm doing my math right.
So that's like two or
three photos a day.
That's not a lot.
I take that many
selfies in one day,
so I'm clearly part
of the problem here.
There, it's just a little slow.
RANDALL SARAFA: So when
we think about messaging,
what we're really thinking
about is connecting people
around the world.
And the most fundamental way you
can do that is by letting them
text each other.
And we've been doing
that for years and years.
But the messaging
space has evolved.
We now let people do
much more than texting.
We let them send
photos and videos.
We let them call
each other over VoIP.
And we let them do this on
a wide variety of platforms,
right?
Obviously, with the goal
of connecting people
around the world,
part of that goal
means allowing everyone
who has any kind of a phone
really talk to one another.
So what does this look
like in the WhatsApp world?
Well, how many people
here, by the way,
have ever used WhatsApp
or are a WhatsApp user?
OK, great.
So you are a very small
fraction of our total user base.
We've got over a billion
people across the globe
using WhatsApp.
It's about one in seven
people on earth using WhatsApp
regularly.
It's a pretty high number.
We've got about 75% of
those users on Android.
And the rest of
them are using one
of our other supported
platforms, which
include iPhone, Windows
Phone, and some older
OSes like BlackBerry, or
some older Nokia platforms
that we developed for.
To give you an
idea of how engaged
those billion users are,
they send a lot of messages.
It's about 42 billion
messages sent per day.
So really, when we're
thinking about WhatsApp,
we're thinking about
a product at scale.
Of course, WhatsApp is
more than just texting.
It includes sending photos
and videos, voice messages,
location messages,
contacts, and most recently,
we let you now send
documents on WhatsApp.
So you could pick a
document from your phone,
pick one from Google
Drive, or another source.
Pretty cool.
Media actually represents a
pretty significant portion
of the messages that
get sent per day.
We've got 1.8 billion photos
sent per day on WhatsApp.
And we've got 250 million
videos sent per day.
So really high usage
in terms of media.
MIKE PROCOPIO: There we are.
Thanks.
So complementing client
devices and client applications
like WhatsApp, we also
have cloud storage.
So data in the cloud is
all about safely storing
what's important to you.
And an important part
of this is the ability
to access your data
from wherever you're at.
So increasingly, that
means mobile devices.
Once things are in the cloud,
sharing and collaboration
becomes easy and
naturally expressed.
In particular, sharing and
collaboration around teams.
And so more and more,
we live in the cloud.
And more and more, we're doing
things via our mobile devices.
DoubleClick.
There we are.
So Google Drive is a
cloud storage system
that is focused on both
enterprise and consumer users.
It's a safe place for
all of your files.
It can store any type
of file that you have,
including some things
that we may not usually
associate as being file-like.
So yes, photos, media,
documents, spreadsheets, text
files, CSVs.
But also things like maps,
and sites, and diagrams.
Things like that.
Importantly, you can view it and
increasingly interact with it.
Not just view, but actually
rich edit from anywhere
across all sorts
of client devices.
Sharing with others is
a key part of the value
that Google Drive delivers.
And then finally, as we'll
see a little bit later,
which is important
to our integration,
there is a large, third
party app ecosystem
with open and mature APIs.
Double tap.
Come on.
Thanks.
So our joint mission,
then, is to work together
to preserve the memories
of a billion users.
RANDALL SARAFA: So why did we
do this in the first place?
Well fundamentally, WhatsApp
doesn't store your messages.
And what I mean by
that is WhatsApp
doesn't store your
messages on our servers.
Really, your chat history
lives on your device.
So all the messages
you're sending,
the media you're sending,
it's all stored on your device
and not somewhere else.
So given that that's
the case, it's
important that if
you switch devices,
or you lose your phone,
or you upgrade phones,
you have the ability to
preserve all the chat
history that you have.
So we thought, for
our Android users,
the best way to do that
would be to use Google Drive.
And there's two
reasons for that.
First, turns out
most Android users
have a Google account already
signed into on their phone.
So this means that a user
can opt into this feature
without having to create
a new account of some kind
or authenticate to
another service.
So it's really
frictionless in that way.
So we're really trying to build
a simple mechanism for users.
Second is Android devices
have really good support
for the Drive APIs,
which means as a user who
wants to backup your
stuff to Google Drive,
you don't need to install
additional software.
Most of the stuff lives
in Google Play Services
So it's ready to go.
As I mentioned
before, we're really
talking about
integration at scale,
which Mike is going to talk a
lot about a little bit later.
Now, in terms of how this
actually works in the product,
we want to walk you through
some of the challenges we had,
and also some of the decisions
we made in terms of how
to design this user experience.
So our backups are opt-in.
What this means is that we
need a user to actually turn
on Google Drive backups.
And we obviously
want a way to do
this that is really
obvious to the user, right?
We want them to know
the feature actually
exists in the first place.
So we designed a
full screen activity
that prompts users to opt
in to Google Drive backups.
And we present them with this
activity on a time interval.
It's about once
every few months.
We ask them kind of upfront
when they're using the app,
and we back off to
once every few months.
By the way, the reason we
do a time-based approach as
opposed to saying,
hey, maybe we'll
ask a user when
they update the app,
is because we update
our frequently.
So that gets annoying.
So you don't want
this to become noise.
You want it to be
meaningful to the user.
First thing we ask them is to
select a backup frequency--
daily, weekly, or monthly.
And the reason we actually do
this is while our backups are
incremental, there's
one part of the backup,
it's a small part of the
backup, that actually gets
backed up fresh every single
time a backup is done.
So by dialing back
the backup frequency,
choosing a less
frequent backup cycle,
you can actually save
some data, some bandwidth.
And importantly, a
lot of WhatsApp users
are very conscious
of the data usage
that they're using because
data around the world
is much more expensive.
So we're trying to build
controls for our users
that allow them to
really say how much data
they want to use and be able
to preserve that if necessary.
We ask them to connect
a Google account.
Most Android users have
just one on their phone,
so we automatically
choose that one.
When they connect
a Google account,
you just get presented
with a system level
prompt asking you to connect
Google Drive to WhatsApp.
It's a permission prompt.
And the last thing
we let users do
is decide whether they want
to backup videos or not.
The reason we do this is
because videos actually
represent a pretty large portion
of the overall backup size,
or they can.
So on average, between a user
who backups videos and one
who chooses not
to do it, there's
about a 300 megabyte
saving on average.
So you can really, if you don't
have much Google Drive storage,
or you don't really want
to expend the bandwidth
to back that up, you can
choose to not include the video
if you want.
OK.
So I opt into backups.
I got my stuff backed up.
Now, how do you actually
get that data, right?
So I switch phones,
or my phone, you know,
drops in a toilet,
something like that.
I get a new phone.
How do you actually get
all your chats back?
Well, we basically ask you to
do this at registration time.
You install WhatsApp, tell
us what your phone number is,
and then we look for a backup.
When we find a backup and the
user decides to restore it,
the restore happens
in two stages.
First, we restore your chats.
And what I mean
by that is really
just the chat database, which
is mostly just text messages.
Doesn't include any media.
So that's a smaller
portion of the backup.
And we do this synchronously.
So we don't let the user into
the app until this finishes.
There's a reason for that.
When the user actually
ends up in the App,
we want them to see all
their chats right away.
Otherwise, they're
going to think
something might have gone wrong,
we lost some of their data,
or something like that.
So we restore the chat
database synchronously.
However, with media,
because that represents
such a large portion of
the overall backup size,
we do that asynchronously.
So we let you into the app.
And if you look at the
bottom screenshot here,
we basically restore the
media in the background.
And we kind of tell you that
at the top of your chat list.
This means the user
doesn't have to sit
around waiting for a huge
backup to restore, potentially.
And if they have slow
network, or they're
doing this over cellular
for some reason,
that way they're in
the app ready to go
and their media will restore.
We actually restore your
most recent media first,
which makes sense,
because you're
most likely to see that
in your chat history.
And we're always monitoring
network conditions.
So we pause the restore
if you drop off Wi-Fi,
or if your battery gets
low, or things like that.
I'll make one comment
about the UI here.
We actually designed
some animations
in the restore process.
And the reason we thought
this was actually important
was that the user has
an extra indication
that progress is happening.
So the dots animate in the top
screenshot, or those two arrows
animate in the bottom
screenshot, letting the user
know something's going on.
When the restore is paused
or something's not happening,
we actually stop
those animations.
So just reinforce in
the UI to the user
what's actually going on.
And from there, you
get your chats back
and you're ready to go.
MIKE PROCOPIO: OK.
So we've had a pretty clear
look on the product side for how
this works, both in terms
of backup and restore
flows, which are the two main
flows in this integration.
Let's back up a little
bit from a-- back up--
from a higher level
view and check out
the architectural overview for
how the overall system works.
So like all good
architecture diagrams,
first off, these colors
I spent a lot of time on.
So I hope that they work.
All good architecture diagrams
start with the storage server.
Storage services on the
bottom, and kind of the clients
at the top.
And that's what we have here.
So notice the Drive clients
and the WhatsApp clients
on the top.
The very bottom, you have
both WhatsApp and Google Drive
backend server technologies.
So on Drive side, and
we'll see this a few times
in this integration,
there's two key services
involved in managing files.
There's the service that
handles binary file content, so
the actual content of the file.
And then all of
the metadata, which
is stored separately and
optimized differently,
because it's a different
kind of use case.
So things like
title and MIME type.
Of course, there's a
business logic on top
of that, and a
good caching layer.
Probably many caching layers.
The solution to all known
computer science problems
and quite a few bugs, actually.
Causing quite a few bugs.
One of the key things
about this slide that
influences our integration
is this Unified First-Party
and Third-Party Drive API.
That's the section
in the middle.
And that's the team that
I'm fortunate to work on.
And what this is, is the
programmatic entry point
into Drive, traditional API.
One of the key takeaways of this
is that the same set of APIs,
the exact same endpoints
and the exact same server
infrastructure, serves
both first-party Drive
clients, like Drive on the web,
Mac, PC, Android, iOS, Chrome
OS, and the entire third-party
ecosystem, including WhatsApp.
So what this means
is there's anything
you can do with a
first party app,
third party app,
minus a few specific
exceptions around security.
And so according to the
diagram, WhatsApp client
has their lightweight
wrapper around Drive APIs.
They're calling the exact same
set of endpoints that we do.
So when the user
ops into backup,
files will become
uploaded via the entry
points in the Drive API,
go through several layers
of caching, and then finally
end up in our storage servers.
Restore is the similar
path on the way back out.
Let's take a look specifically
at what a backup flow looks
like, because this is a
pretty brilliant engineering
piece on behalf of the WhatsApp
product and engineering team.
So at the end of the day,
we're making API calls
against the Drive API.
That's the methods that
you see here on the left.
Traditional create,
read, update, delete,
CRUD, RESTful API
sorts of methods.
These should probably--
these may look familiar.
So first, we're going
to look for backups.
That's what this list is about.
We're actually
querying by title.
We're looking for both
the main folder that
indicates a backup is present,
as well as the media folder.
Every backup has
a file map which
contains a list of the IDs of
the files stored in Drive that
match the media on the device.
So we're basically
looking for that.
Once we find it, we read it in.
And then we begin the backup.
And what this means is doing
a differential comparison
between what's on
the device and what
was on the existing file map.
So it's basically
a diff, because one
of the important
things is we don't
want to re-upload things
we've already uploaded.
Bandwidth conservation is
critical for this use case.
Finally, so we'll start
uploading media items.
We'll upload the
message database.
And we'll upload
the new file map.
And then something
very important happens.
This fourth line
from the bottom,
this properties.Insert call,
up to this point, the network
connection could fail,
the phone could disappear,
and the user's backup
would still be intact.
This is a really sound, defense
in-depth, robust engineering
on behalf of the
WhatsApp client.
Because it means that
only when we finally
make this switch to
the new file map,
updating a pointer basically,
is the new backup in place.
Finally, we'll do some cleanup
and deleting the old files.
Any items that are not on
the device that were in Drive
are also cleaned up.
Restore flow is
comparatively simple.
[INAUDIBLE] reads tend to be
a little easier than writes.
We look for a backup.
If a backup is present,
we can prompt the user,
as we'll see in our demo.
We'll get the contents
of the file map
to actually find the IDs.
And then we'll begin background
restoration of the user's media
in the background.
And then at that point,
the user can begin
using WhatsApp right away.
So quick technical details.
I have a slide here.
Randall has one as well.
As far as HTTP Libraries,
we use HttpURLConnection
on most modern devices.
This integration, Drive backup
is supported fairly-- on I
think Gingerbread.
But for older devices, we will
use the Apache http library.
Authentication is typically
a very tricky area,
but on Android,
fundamentally, what it
comes down to is
using Oauth2, where
you can get a token,
which is available
built in Android APIs.
And then finally, you have to
pass that token in a RESTful
API call as part of a header.
And then finally, rate
limiting is important,
both in terms of
client and server.
Things can fail on the
server, transient errors,
that kind of a thing.
So the client has robust
retry with exponential backoff
implemented.
RANDALL SARAFA: A few
other technical details.
So we actually use the HTTP API
for Google Drive, rather than
the Drive Java SDK.
The reason we do this is
the SDK is kind of big
and it was pushing us up
against our 64K method limit,
so we decided to
go with HTTP API.
It's also a little bit
more flexible in terms
of how we could design some of
the calls that we were making.
I also want to mention
the backup window.
When do we actually back up?
And we do this to optimize--
we choose a backup window that
optimizes for whether the
person's phone is going to be
charged and connected to Wi-Fi.
So we think, usually, that
this happens at night.
Right?
When you're sleeping.
So you charge your
phone at night.
If you're at home, you
probably have Wi-Fi.
So we kind of optimized
for that condition.
So we basically say-- we
pick a four-hour window.
I think it's like 2:00 and 6:00
AM, between 2:00 and 6:00 AM.
And we basically,
for a given user,
randomize when they'll back up.
The reason we choose a random
time for the user backup
is so that we don't really
bring down Google servers
by having a bunch of people
have their phones wake up
at 2:00 AM, take a backup off.
This would be pretty bad.
So we kind of choose
a random window.
That helps us really
get where we want.
And of course, we're always
looking for network conditions,
battery, et cetera.
So we won't kick a backup off
if your phone's battery is low.
We won't kick one
off if you're not
in the right network condition.
But once you are in
those proper conditions,
we'll just start the backup.
So if I am asleep
at night, my phone
is dead, by the time I
get to work in the morning
and plug my phone
into the charger,
we'll just kick the backup
off for that day at that time.
So we're kind of flexible,
actually, in that way.
So where are we at today?
So we fully rolled the feature
out in January of this year.
Took several months to actually
roll it out completely.
And we're going to talk
about the rollout process
a little bit later.
As I mentioned before, we've
got over a billion people
on WhatsApp.
75% of them are in Android.
And of our Android
users, we have about 40%
of them opted into Google
Drive backups today.
So pretty good numbers.
That will likely continue
to increase over time
as people get prompted,
as I mentioned,
once every few months.
MIKE PROCOPIO: Good.
Well, I know we
make it look easy,
but the truth is there
were a lot of challenges
along the way.
And we're going to
take a very transparent
behind-the-scenes look at
what some of these were.
So first and foremost, with
an integration like WhatsApp,
we think scale.
How can we accommodate
an integration this size?
With a billion users
with daily backups,
backing up new content
as it's generated.
How do we absorb the
initial backup data
that's on the user device
when they're opted in?
Because that's a
large initial upload.
And then once that's finished,
it's more of a natural thing.
Multiply by a billion
users and things
start to-- times an
opt-in rate, and things
start to get very
interesting quickly.
Large scale can mean a
lot of different things.
Users-- and we're talking a
billion times the opt-in rate,
that's measured in hundreds
of millions of users.
Drive API queries
per second-- if you
have that many users
backing up at night,
you're talking queries into
the hundreds of thousands
of uploads per second, which is
pretty intense for any service.
That takes a lot.
It requires a lot of instances
of Drive server backends.
At the end of the day,
Drive, and the API, and all
the backend, it is a server.
We're listening for
requests on a socket.
And any given JDM, any
given task or instance
can only handle so many.
And so what do we do?
We just start spinning up
lots of these instances
to handle all the
requests as they come in.
And load balancing kind
of comes into play there.
Also, not just in terms
of the server production
engineering, but the
storage capacity matters.
Both in terms of
size of the items
stored, which matters
when we're writing
file content to
the binary service,
as well as raw number of items.
So for all of
these reasons, this
is a super large
scale integration
that takes a lot of
very careful planning.
In particular, when we talk
about capacity planning,
we're talking
about provisioning.
And the conversation went
a little bit like this.
Somebody heard that we were
working on a WhatsApp thing,
as they called it.
And they asked me
how big it was.
I was like, pretty big.
And so at Google,
we think pretty big.
They're like oh, it's like
a Gmail, we can handle that.
It's like, no, it
might be bigger.
And at that point, people
start to get a little nervous
because if you don't
properly provision,
you're going to take
down-- truly take down
and overwhelm active servers
that are trying to fill
requests from other people.
So provisioning and estimation
is critical, especially
for an integration of this size.
So we need to estimate it.
Well, how can we do that?
Two general approaches, just to
kind of give a quick overview
of how we do this in practice.
You can model it.
You can model it
from first principle.
So you have a theoretical
way to do estimates.
Total number of users
times opt-in rate, number
of files that every
person has, number of
files that each user generates
over time on a daily basis.
Different types require
different resources.
For example, videos
get transcoded
into multiple
formats for playback
on different platforms.
So they'll impact us
in different ways.
So that's your model.
And like all good models,
there's some saying about this.
They're useful to
varying degree.
What we find to be a little
more reliable, in this case,
is empirical observation.
So we do a trial rollout
with WhatsApp's beta users.
They have an excellent
beta program.
And then we say,
that's a portion
of the overall user base.
Let's multiply it by
that scalar factor.
In our case, these
two roughly agreed,
and so that gave
us good confidence
that these are the resources
that we need to provision.
RANDALL SARAFA: So want
to talk a little bit
about bandwidth reduction.
As I mentioned, WhatsApp
users-- we have users
all around the world.
And so we're really
interested in making sure
that we're using only the amount
of data that we need to use.
Making sure that's efficient
and trying to speed things up.
Trying to make backups
quick, restores quick.
So one of the primary
ways we do this is backups
are incremental,
for the most part.
So this means that if I
backed up a photo one day,
I don't need to go and back
that up the next time I go ahead
and kick off the backup.
Makes sense.
One of the other
ways we do this is we
actually have byte level resumes
for uploads and downloads
of every file.
So if I'm uploading a photo
and the connection drops,
and for some reason
I don't finish it,
I can actually just resume at
the byte level of that upload.
Really efficient to do that.
So this especially comes in
handy with larger media files.
If you think about a video
that might be 16 megabytes,
this type of thing
actually comes in handy.
We also optimize a
lot of our API calls.
We do batch deletes
to remove files.
So a user goes and
deletes a bunch
of photos from a WhatsApp chat.
The next day when
we do the backup,
we're going to need to
delete those files out
of Google Drive.
So we batch those up and do it.
And when we're fetching
files at the time of restore,
we actually fetch the metadata
for those files simultaneously.
So we don't have to make
sequential API calls in order
to actually do that.
The last thing I'll say
is when we're actually
fetching the metadata for files,
we only look at the fields
that we really need.
There are, I think,
dozens and dozens of them.
And we actually only
look at about a handful.
So we're actually optimizing
how we're actually
reading the metadata so that
we can, again, optimize the API
call for efficiency.
MIKE PROCOPIO: All right.
Another challenge is it has
to be fast and it has to work.
We call that performance
and reliability.
We have a saying, fast
is our favorite feature.
Speed matters.
We are a service, right?
We are designed to
fulfill requests
from all sorts of applications,
often where a user is waiting.
Speed actually counts.
For backup it's a
little bit different.
It's attended.
So typically between the
hours of 2:00 and 6:00
AM in a backup window,
sequential upload is OK.
Speed is not as critical,
but at the same time,
we do want to be fast.
While if we're slow, the device
is still on, we're using Wi-Fi,
we're using connectivity.
That translates to battery.
So we want to be as lean as
possible, even on the server,
even for an unattended use case.
Restore is attended.
The user is waiting.
As we've seen in the demo,
we're restoring our items,
they're in the background.
Maybe the user is waiting for
that content to be restored.
So it's important to be fast.
One way we can get around this
is to parallelize downloads.
It turns out that pulling
bytes from concurrent streams
works pretty well, scales well,
and doesn't chew up any more
CPU than you would
expect from linear.
And you get the expected, almost
theoretically optimal, speed
up in terms of user
perceived latency.
So fast is great.
But if it doesn't work
at all, then basically
it took an infinite
amount of time.
So we have to actually
answer the request.
Reliability is important.
This is hard for backup.
This is hard for writes.
Because you're writing
to multiple systems.
You're dealing with 4
or 5 megabyte files.
You're buffering things.
You're chunking.
You're opening up
upload sessions.
You're finalizing them.
You're writing the metadata.
Once that's done, you're
doing post-processing.
We have to do this
super reliably.
What does reliable mean?
Well, I mean, that's
a varying degree.
But in general, if you are
talking about, for example,
only one in 100,000, or
one in a million requests
failing in that kind of
range, that's pretty good.
Because for the
requests that do fail,
a simple retry will
likely clear it up
and users will
generally have no idea.
So four [INAUDIBLE] for
example, is a reasonable target,
and it's quite a
feat when you're
talking about writing
data at that scale.
RANDALL SARAFA: So
despite all our best
efforts for reliability,
things actually do go wrong.
And this is actually--
handling errors is actually
both an engineering challenge
as well as a user experience
challenge.
Here's why.
When something goes
wrong, you don't
want to constantly tell the
user that something is wrong.
Otherwise they start to think
your service is reliable.
This is especially
true for things
that happen where we can
recover gracefully from them.
So I'll give you an example.
Let's say the user's phone
isn't on in the backup window.
So their phone is off at night.
We realize we can't perform
a backup at 2:00 AM.
We'll just wait and defer
the backup until later
in the day when the
proper conditions are met.
Same is true for network.
Sometimes we get miscellaneous
server errors, like error 500,
that we don't really know
exactly what's going on.
So we just kind of wait.
We try the backup again.
If it works, it works.
If it doesn't, we're still
kind of silent about it.
And I'll tell you
when we're not.
So we have a class of
errors where it actually--
so that's a class of errors that
we can recover silently from,
but we've also got
this class of errors
that require user action
in order to recover from.
So great example of
this is authentication.
Let's say you go and change
your Google password.
You forget to update it
on your Android device.
Well at this point,
we can't actually
authenticate into Google
Drive in order to back up.
So we actually tell the user
immediately for that type
of an error to go
resolve this issue,
because we know that no
matter how many times we're
going to try this
backup, it's never
going to work unless the
user does something about it.
Another type of error that
happens in this category
is storage issues.
Let's say you run out
of Google Drive quota,
or your phone runs
out of storage.
Those types of things.
Again, we tell the
user explicitly, please
go fix this thing.
So for the errors that we think
we can recover gracefully from,
what we do is we keep trying
and we don't tell the user
this backup hasn't
occurred for several days.
So say I have daily backup set.
One day the backup doesn't work.
We just kind of wait.
We try it the next day.
If it works, it works.
Great.
If by, I think, like the fourth
or fifth day, at that point,
we'll tell the user something
maybe is not going on.
But really, we're trying
to just do this gracefully.
The balance we're really
trying to strike, of course,
is you don't want to annoy
the user into thinking
this thing isn't working.
But also, you want
the user to actually
be able to back their stuff up.
Because even losing one, two,
three, four days of messages
could be pretty
painful sometimes.
Hurts to lose that data.
OK.
Let's talk a little
bit about rollout.
And we're going to
cover this in detail.
So how did we roll this out?
Well, we distribute
WhatsApp in two ways.
We've got an APK download that
we distribute on our website.
And we also distribute it
through the Play Store.
Obviously, a vast
majority of our users
get it from the Play Store.
What this means, however,
is that you can actually
test things, test updates,
with the website population,
because the population is
small, and you can actually
use that almost like
a beta testing pool.
So we started there.
And we did this as a
percentage rollout.
So we said, hey, we'll roll this
out to 5% of our website users
and then ramp that up.
And then we did a
percentage rollout
for our Play Store users.
Percentage rollout's really
important, obviously,
because we don't want to just
turn this on all at once.
We want to find the bugs
that we have in the client.
We want to make sure the
servers can handle it.
All those types of things.
So we monitor this very closely.
Because again, we're
dealing with user data.
This stuff is precious.
You don't want to screw it up.
Of course, even when you're
doing your percentage rollout,
one thing to keep in mind is
that there is a natural user
upgrade cycle.
So say we ship a
version of WhatsApp
with Google Drive in it.
We enable it for 5% of users.
Not everyone's on
that build yet,
so they're going to
upgrade over time.
So actually, in absolute
numbers, the 5% grows.
So keep that in mind.
It's another interesting thing
that we have to deal with.
Towards the end of
the rollout cycle,
we shifted from a percentage
rollout to a regional rollout.
Mike's going to tell you why
we did that in a little bit.
And of course, just some
critical things that we did.
Client monitoring
was really important.
So we were constantly
monitoring success rates
for backups and restores.
We were constantly monitoring
if a backup was failing,
what type of error
were we seeing?
And this let us find bugs
and make optimizations
along the way to make all
of this more reliable.
On Mike's side,
they were obviously
doing a lot of server monitoring
to make sure we didn't
bring down Google's servers.
Which we mostly didn't.
And communication is key.
So actually, our teams
communicated frequently.
Every time there
was a client change
that we thought would affect the
way the server would respond,
we communicated that.
And we still do that today.
So communication,
really good when
you're dealing with
this type of thing.
MIKE PROCOPIO: OK.
So let's take a look at what the
rollout actually looked like.
And we'll speed things
up here a little bit.
This is an actual
graph of queries
to the Drive API from WhatsApp.
So you kind of see on the left,
we had our preview rollout
where we're kind of
testing things out
to see how things are scaling.
Everything was working great.
From that, we're
able to understand
how much provisioning we need.
So there's kind
of a quiet period
while we allocate the
resources, plan the rollout.
And then we start gradually
bumping things up.
A couple of percent,
3% at a time.
We wait for that and we
see how things behave.
Then at some point, we are
ready to do daily rollouts.
That's the section
in the middle.
Not a whole lot of sleeping
right now during this phase.
3% a day until it
was basically done.
There was an interesting point
that we'll talk about here
where we had to pause the
rollout for some regions.
We'll take a look why.
And then after the new
year, we resumed it.
And then towards
the end, we kind of
had this natural, linear-esque
growth at full rollout.
Next slide.
So one quick look for one of
the more interesting things
that happened in the rollout.
So data centers and services.
There are lots of data
centers around the world.
They are not
uniformly distributed.
And what that means is that
you have the local data centers
where file uploads will go.
But also at Google,
and many places,
not all servers or services
will run in every data center.
Seems like it's fine and
you just bounce the traffic
back and forth.
But it turns out
to be interesting
in the following scenario.
So broadly speaking here,
we have data centers
on various continents.
There's a data center
that accepts upload
on the west of the Pacific.
And there's a data center
east of the Pacific
that Drive runs in,
and particularly
the metadata storage layer.
What was happening was we
were uploading the data
to the local data center.
That was great.
Super low latency.
It was good.
Post-processing around checksums
had to be done in Drive
because checksums are
part of the metadata.
To do that, we needee--
to do calculated checksum,
you need the file content.
Drive did not run in
the local data center
that the file upload
service ran in.
So what was happening
was Drive was
pulling all of the
bytes across the Pacific
from that data center.
I mean, ultimately,
we're shipping bytes
in a pipe across an ocean.
That pipe is very much limited.
It's expensive to use.
And if you saturate
it, things like YouTube
could start to be impacted.
So we had to pause our
rollout for the regions that
were impacted.
And here is what we did.
The solution to this was to--
well, we paused the rollout.
We moved the
post-processing in Drive,
and particularly
the checksumming,
into the same data
centers associated
with the regional uploads.
So then all the
post-processing was done.
We didn't have to
transfer petabytes
upon petabytes back and forth.
And everybody was happy.
We were able to gradually
resume the rollout.
That was a very interesting
kind of scenario.
Quick look at the
API and ecosystem.
And I think we're doing
pretty well here on time.
We'll have time for a demo here.
So the Drive API has been
around for almost 10 years now.
And very powerful
and expressive.
It can do a lot of things
that you would expect around
file management, uploads
and downloads, of course,
applicable to our use case.
Revisions, listening for
changes on a file or a folder
or Drive-wide.
Full programmatic management
of sharing and permissions.
Applicable to this integration,
the use of custom third party
properties.
Push notifications.
And as we noted before, the
first party Drive clients-- so
Drive on web and
Android, iOS, everything,
all use the same set of APIs.
So we have a rich third
party ecosystem because we've
had open API since 2008.
This is part of our platform.
This is not an afterthought.
Embracing the
developer community
is part of our MO,
our DNA, our vision.
It is something that we are
paying a lot of close attention
to.
So apps that do everything
imaginable have popped up
in the past almost decade--
faxing, editing, rendering,
syncing and backup, data
protection, data validation,
data integrity, enterprise
use cases, document work
flows, games, music players,
anything you can think of
has probably been done
in this ecosystem.
So this is an example of
what some of the apps look
like right now on
the Chrome Web Store.
The variety of apps is
reflective of increasing number
of Android apps embracing
Drive APIs for varying
degrees, including
storage and backup,
like the WhatsApp use case.
All right.
Here is a graph of
Drive API growth.
And one of the key
things to take away here
is that we want to embrace
the third party community.
And what that means
is we understand
that scale is important.
We know how to scale, and
we understand that your apps
need to scale as well.
So whatever quota you
need, we are able to grant.
We are watching
this very carefully,
and we're provisioning
along the way.
And you can see we have a
nice kind of linear growth
that we're planning for
on an ongoing basis.
And as long as it
continues roughly linearly,
people are generally happy here.
So this looks great.
Last 300 days on that.
All right.
Demo time.
RANDALL SARAFA:
You want to do it?
MIKE PROCOPIO: Yeah.
I think we have a perfect
amount of time here.
So we wanted to demo
the end-to-end flow.
What could possibly go
wrong, as we like to say.
We can switch over here.
So what we'll do is Randall and
I have a conversation going,
if that's showing up there.
Yep.
We're going to take a selfie.
We're going to back it up.
We're going to clear
the data on the device
and then attempt a restore using
Google I/O Wi-Fi, because we
like to live dangerously.
OK, bud.
Here we go.
RANDALL SARAFA: 50/50 shot.
MIKE PROCOPIO: Exactly.
All right.
What are we-- are we smiling,
are we striking a pose?
Here let's-- OK.
Excellent.
All right.
Yo.
Maybe just an emoji there
just for good measure.
All right.
So there it is showing up there.
Looks good.
All right.
So to trigger manual backup, the
user can back up at any time.
I have mine set up to
update backup every night,
chats, and chat backup.
We can also backup manually.
So first we create
a local backup.
We're going to query
Drive to figure out
what things are there, what
things are on the device,
and do that kind of
differential computation.
We figure it out.
We upload the new photo.
That's happening fairly
quickly, which is great.
When that's done,
remember as we saw
before, we update the
pointer to the new file
map, which basically says, this
backup is live and ready to go.
That's what's happening now.
It's done.
In and out in 15 or 20 seconds.
RANDALL SARAFA: So that's
also the incremental backup
happening right there.
So you see how quick
it's actually going.
MIKE PROCOPIO: Right.
RANDALL SARAFA: It's just
a minor amount of data
has changed in between.
MIKE PROCOPIO: So let's go
ahead and clear things off
of the device.
So first off, what
we can do-- and I'll
show you the coolest
little-- there we are.
Yep.
So that'll get us into storage.
Clear off the data and the
cache from the local device.
And then importantly,
we also need
to go into the actual
built-in storage manager
here on Android, which is
a neat little thing that I
found under Storage and USB.
If you scroll down, there's this
cool little thing, explorer,
here.
This is a natural built-in
Android file manager.
So you go to WhatsApp.
WhatsApp stores its
media on the SD card.
And I can actually go
ahead and clear that.
RANDALL SARAFA: Basically
what we're doing
is we're simulating what
would happen if someone
got a new phone, right?
Like they're not going to really
have any data on their phone
yet.
They're not going to
have WhatsApp installed.
So all these things don't
really exist, right?
So what happens in the world
when you get a new phone.
So you install WhatsApp.
You're back at registration.
We're going to ask you for
your phone number first.
MIKE PROCOPIO: So we
are officially now
in a kind of a zero state.
Cleared off everything,
as Randall said.
We'll uninstall it.
And then I actually have
a local version of it
right here under Downloads.
WhatsApp APK.
So we'll install
it locally again.
And that should trigger the
restore flow once it installs.
So what that'll do is
it will-- opting in,
the user will be prompted
to be able to restore
their items when it's ready.
This happens after account
setup and verification, which
is based on your phone number.
And then the key thing
to note about restore
is that all the
media is actually
restored in the background.
Anything else you want to say
about this flow in general?
RANDALL SARAFA: What
we'll show you right now
is where we do this as
part of the process.
One thing to keep in mind,
when we look for backups
and registration, it kind of
requires the Google account
being on the device.
So we have some
logic for letting
the user know like, hey,
maybe you don't have
a Google account on your phone.
If you've backed
up previously, why
don't you go ahead and sign in
so you can actually restore it.
We also only give you one
opportunity to restore.
That's at install time.
The reason is because it
creates a lot of complexity
to do it later in terms of
how you merge chat databases
and do all those
types of things.
So we just kind of give you
the opportunity up front,
restore it.
It's just much more
reliable to do it that way.
MIKE PROCOPIO: All right.
I set up my account.
It was automatically
verified by SMS.
You can see the
notification there.
And then here, as Randall just
noted, we looked for a backup
and we found a backup.
We have the opportunity to
restore it from the cloud.
RANDALL SARAFA: So
importantly, we're
also showing the user
the size of this.
We say, this is how much we're
actually going to download.
So when Mike actually hits
Restore, what we're doing
is what I mentioned before.
We're restoring the
chat database first.
We do this synchronously.
So these are your messages.
We let you know, hey,
6,000 of them are restored.
And we actually tell
the user, your media
will be restored
in the background.
So when Mike actually
comes into WhatsApp,
you're going to see something
at the top of the chat list that
says restoring media.
And that's going to kick
off getting all your photos,
your videos, et cetera, which
again, are the biggest part
of a user's backup, typically.
You can see that right there.
As I mentioned before, we
restored the most recent media
first.
So if you actually
go into our chat,
you'll probably see
the photo that Mike
sent already restored.
So we optimized for
recent messages,
which obviously makes sense.
You want to see
that stuff up front.
And that's our demo.
MIKE PROCOPIO: Cool.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you everyone for your
attention for being here today.
We really appreciated having
a chance to kind of give you
a behind the scenes look here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]